so basically first of all I know I'm
[ __ ] but I also know I'm special
undersized wanted get that I was cool so
basically do you know how I got this
meeting
I don't remember okay so basically I own
a barter system in Canada yes and this
barter guy we met at hasten hustle
briefly yes remember I'm in st.
Catharines yes I remember okay and bass
I remember you'd remember now I remember
perfect so yeah I just want to get in
front of you obviously there was a ton
of noise after that you had told me in a
video I have it I have a video recorded
where you'd say yeah you know tweet me
I'll see it I believe in what you're
doing you know I do I try attempted to
get in touch with me which is no big
deals tons of stuff coming out yet so I
basically found another way because I
wasn't getting hurt so I happen to know
a guy who had the at d-roc Instagram
username alright
amazing I remember this part too I
didn't know they were connected but I
never met but I know that story too I
said I have to use a barter you actually
yeah you X he executed on your thesis
exactly I love it I got in touch with
d-roc he had been attempting to get the
username from some guy before and I've
never had never got in there got it so I
have to know this guy so I traded him a
horse a custom horse saddle for his
daughter who's in showjumping treated
him the custom horse saddle through a
trade ban client of mine my barter
system he was able to take the saddle I
got the drop Instagram username I made a
deal with the rock he gave me the ask
and Here I am so I can love it it's
awesome right amazing I use barter to
get a meeting to talk about barter I
love it and this is what I've super meta
and what is it I mean it worked out way
better for you this way then if I would
have just replied to the tweet what it
did 100% no this is my biggest thesis
right which is like everybody like like
just gives up yeah anyway it's why it's
wire like barter so much it's a move
that people don't have in their
repertoire exactly it's it's lost it's
how we all used to roll yeah chicken for
hay hay for [ __ ] you know a massage
like rocks for [ __ ] water like this
is like this is our currency
exactly I'm a bit I mean I've always
dreamed of
building this is this why I responded so
emphatically to you yeah for a long time
in the 90s my belief was the startup
that would make me buy the Jets was to
build the BART or eBay right you know
can still can't believe it actually it's
being scratched by a lot of little
things um I'm a fan so anyway what can i
what can I help you with this before we
run out of time bartering artery I've
been why 20 years old how did it start
it started with me coming out of high
school I was moved to engineering I got
started in sales with an alarm company
realized I could close and and just went
straight to sales met a guy who was at
the barter business and tromped the
classic media barter business like that
one that's kind of sometimes dirty
sometimes clean we kept artery so what
would that mean that would be like small
to medium sized businesses where it's
it's all it's all on its own platform
it's organized like you know it was
called barbers it's a change at the time
but it's called trading bank now right I
would say I have a thousand cases of a
wine that I can't move in my store and
somebody would say I want that I've got
correct so I just deal with a winery in
Niagara region as you know by the way
just before I forget I brought you a
thank you honking yeah love it so
basically I just helped this winery
trade off about a hundred grand worth of
long inventory that was taking up space
in their warehouse they we're gonna have
to discount it like 50 percent to get
rid of it
you got full value they got full value
in their barter account we're help them
construct a new building and get
advertising a medium of exchange yes and
I made a whole bunch of clients really
really have you anytime because they got
them at Christmastime so what percentage
of the barter on the trade Bank and all
that is that world of barter that I that
I understand much more which is you get
full value of your product you get
median return the people in the middle
are playing on both sides and are making
their margin versus wine for markers
yeah so I totally get three dollars or I
get there I got it I understand that so
that I understand how much of the
ecosystem is the established media
barter world that I know very well you
know where people trading media
versus stuff for stuff or services for
services that don't include advertising
well yes I understand yes we're just on
your world I'm just curious
Spanish business okay business onboard
when do people still do a lot of cash in
your world
welcome actually captioning I mean US
dollars or community I understand it's a
lot of that too but a trade bank what we
do is a small portions and we we we
basically promote that any business
should never barter more than three to
ten percent of their annual sales and
that's additional new business
incremental sales on top of their
regular cash paying customer business
right now so what we do is we generate
looks like a funny trade that you've
seen that yeah give me a historically
funny trade or just one now I would deem
unusual as somebody who doesn't know the
world as well well just it's very
unusual for people to say well I was
able to offer Company B one right now a
tough we're leading right you were
already tough yeah of course national
brand international red so we had a
Tupperware lady who was in Saskatoon
Saskatchewan way out in western yeah I
know it she wanted to renovate her home
right well she can have to go kind of
check and pay money out of her pocket or
she can actually do the smart way and
and trade Tupperware for construction so
we helped her sell about $60,000 worth
of Tupperware to Tupperware you gifts in
exchange for the construction of our new
home and incentivizing her downline
static our downline the marketing team
to actually do more sales so that's
that's something that people are like
blown away by so we making from
marketing to advertising to construction
to retail to restaurants and wineries to
I mean I'm getting married this year in
December and we've got the photographer
the limo soup rental all of that through
trade right right and what do you and
what did you give them in return working
for John yeah
trade dollars it's all of our earnings
enjoyed the treatment currency I think
yes if the trade make currency monetizes
the system so what happens is like
understand passion is that there's so
much business waste out there
it's a highly profitable business when
you're the platform yes it really is but
Matt's not mainstream enough because a
lot of people got a lot of dirty people
in it exactly especially in the media
side
it's gotta be legitimized and my passion
is that there's so many businesses out
there that are wasting away they got so
what what can I so consider we have so
little time and now that I'm grounded
yes what do you think I can do for you
right you get to write the script I'm
what is this what I want to do is is I'd
love to be on the askgaryvee show
yes as an expert in retail business
barter to train your people the
marketers how to train their clients how
to capitalize on their downtime idle
Vittori so let's all see so that's are
they understood so to answer that
question much like the same reason I
don't give quotes on books the only
people that are on askgaryvee are people
that i've really got some deep knowledge
of because I'm scared shitless scared
shitless yeah
compounded with the fact that you are in
the industry that is far more scary to
me than a person on TV or a songwriter
or things of that nature the answer is
it's not inconceivable I'm not against
it I'm concerned that I have to do real
work to get to the yes that I'm not so
sold I'm excited about doing right so
help me crack that okay let's go work
backwards for a minute let me play it a
different way why get so why not
accomplish the same thing without me
being the gatekeeper that puts you on
the speed in which it happens right yeah
yeah you know that's the thing I always
think about I became ink and fortune and
Wall Street Journal so that I didn't
have to rely on them putting me on the
thing that I'm trying to do for a lot of
people ironically is show them how to do
it so that they're not then at the mercy
of me putting them on so I wonder if I'm
trying to think of like there's on that
note I'm trying to think about like how
I can help but keep going
you're one of the best obviously at
helping businesses reach a business to
consumer market in terms of digital
media have you worked with or do you be
the baby to be done that's where I make
a lot of my money I'm coming one minute
one minute promise yes let me tell you
exactly how you do it you should start a
weekly podcast or is already doing a
video podcast now or like what do you
date it now yeah
you need a weekly minimum weekly minimum
there
I think podcast is really good for this
space I love it I just think it's good
well so LinkedIn is where I get most of
my bills their cents b2b you're gonna
love what I'm about to say whether it's
video or audio the number one way for
you to get people is to spend a hundred
to a thousand dollars a week on Facebook
Ads
against the segmentation that is called
employees of so you can go to the 20
biggest businesses in Ottawa in
Vancouver in Winnipeg in Calgary and
Saskatchewan and run your content I
would do it like this does your CEO know
does your CFO know does your like
literally the video starts with this
your CFO know and you target it and and
you just do your thing
word video audio on explaining why and I
would attack it right away with I'm
aware why some people are unaware or
cynical to barb barter let me give you
the history of it yeah you need to get
maybe you'll even more educated than you
are oh yeah you know what I mean like
what really happened in the 70s and 60s
and took right yeah but Facebook ads
against employees of who then see it on
their feed and then forward it to their
CFL right it kills it kills you it kills
ya it's the secret sauce that's using
this the C market to get to the
community market right now leverage them
as your sales reps by making the
creative say does your CFO now know yeah
they're like does my CFO got it yeah and
then three of those 800 people have the
courage to forward if their CFO
exact CFO gets three emails on the same
thing she watches yeah overshot it
90% watches yeah okay that's cool I
think I had something else about this oh
one more thing I have my list and we
might have to cut this this is kind of a
private thing out of the the show leader
if it ends up being on but I have a
friend of mine who is a pretty big
business guy in Niagara he's launching a
brand new retail winery store right on
the busiest Highway right there in
Niagara but doesn't have to be stay
controlled cuz that's how you know in
Canada no I don't believe it does no not
if they're actually opening up a winery
a brand new winery understand selling
retail wine other Thunder Station yep
and so we're where am I going
cool yeah so we're looking one man
actually looking for if you'd be
interested in exploring obviously I may
consider but exploring the idea of
owning or partly owner very what's gonna
be a very large retail wine store right
if you guys yeah let's send me all the
information let me put my lawyer
cuz the legal liquor laws in America are
so convoluted I want to make sure it
doesn't [ __ ] me up yeah but thrilled to
look at it you look at that I would look
at that so when you come to Toronto in
February yes for generation now yes
maybe we can arrange I'm thrilled to
explore that further explore okay and
then the other thing was how do i how do
I stay in touch to karaoke now email
email of it you know all right thanks
possible I should take care
[Music]